Oh shucks see how many vibe to okay from
this it is the best day of the year it's
4/20 and you know what that means
CEOs birthday really matured we're like
420 isn't like party like hi you know
like I never really was for me but it's
like my son's birthday
so Theo's here he's being a good boy on
the ground so I don't really want to
pick him up no chewing on a water bottle
he's preparing for his segment later
where we're gonna do CEO like you've
never seen him before if you've seen him
like you've never seen him before but
he's aged almost six months so much
older and wiser and we're gonna reflect
on the past year of his life yeah from
going from small-town Texas boy to the
big city Theo that he is and that even
in the big city feel like the big city
star with 60k Instagram followers do you
have any thoughts like just dream of
that living in the city with 60k
Instagram followers no he's the best
life he's living the dream he was I
think that all the time I do has the
best life and like he doesn't have to
worry about like paying bills going to
work yes and no because like yes he
doesn't worry about paying bills but
then he can't afford to go to your show
yeah that's true that's true but I'm
actually yesterday my bet doctor Lisa
she is like it has an Instagram page it
like gives out like really good pet
advice and she has a podcast with her
boyfriend who's a stand-up comic called
pets and punchlines and I did it
yesterday and like the whole episode was
about duty it's coming out on Monday
it's really funny did she tell you
anything about the OBD being out there
he's chewing on his no self cuz look the
black thing came off why the water
bottle oh oh damn okay are you just
gonna watch I can't put my fingers in
that see oh we got him okay okay here
we're gonna talk about Theo and talk to
Theo in a little bit we're gonna reflect
on his first year you know all the major
milestones developments emotionally and
physically that he's gone through I came
prepared and until then we're obviously
gonna hit you with the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and tell you a bite out of your morning
commute observable I'll both - I know
how to fake juggle balls I always
thought that this was juggling yeah
that's fugly it's not because I'm like
it's supposed to be like
yeah yeah no but it's more like here
wait I'll show you this is how you do it
I'm really not even using the third one
here this is okay
very impressive
so one feels dumb at the water bottle we
came prepared
I can't believe that didn't entice him I
know he could be a little bit of like a
pain in the ass okay anyways fast my
stories that are you know honestly I'm
not gonna I sometimes like you must know
the Fast Five stories of the day today
you can live without it but you must
watch this totally jump in I just hope
everyone like who has like friends flick
aren't toasters yeah they're like family
members are trying to get into I really
hope you send them yesterday's episode
like I couldn't stop thinking about what
a good episode yesterday well and it was
like it was nothing special it was just
us doing our thing talking about the
past five stories just Baltimore good we
were good to small town I was living in
the big city with 60k Instagram
followers
we wish okay let's jump right into the
fast guy story saying you need to know
before you wake up and burn your own
morning toast I can't believe it's
Friday like this is such a gift no no I
can't leave it's Friday because we have
we have this trip next week that I've
probably been looking forward to for
like two months it's always been this
like trip in the distance and now it's
like here like I'd to get a manicure and
like right hand machine and like it's
amazing when are you gonna do that I
think I'm Saturday day impending that
I'm not too hungover what are you doing
tonight oh my god so many things care to
share with the class okay I have like
two Shabbat dinners you know one that's
a little bit more conservative one
that's like kind of less then every
birthday party and that's it okay well
first Nicole Kidman Rihanna and Jennifer
Lopez top times most influential people
of 2018 I have to be honest just shower
I did like a slideshow of all the
different time covers and it said so
many people on the side who are their
most influential and I agree with
everything I mean that usually that's
not about time influential it's like
they don't beat around the bush when it
comes like obviously kylie jenner's
influential but like some people would
put like Malala in front of Kylie when
like Malala is very influential she has
an amazing story but like Kylie's much
more influential you know team I think
the obvious choice is like always there
for time like they don't beat around the
bush which I really like yeah
and also a lot of the interviews are
liked by fellow cohorts so like Tiffany
Haddish is interviewed by Kevin bards
that Nicole came in and Jennifer Lopez
are among Times Magazine's 100 most
influential people of 2018 you know what
is an injustice though and I'm gonna
have to say
that vo is not one of times most
influential I mean look at him he's
[ __ ] devastated yeah Instagram
followers he's so influenced changing
just the game I want to say something
though like there's a difference between
being famous and being influential
kidman I'm in love but I don't know how
influential she's been like I was like a
follower of her I agree like when she's
in a commercial I'm not like oh I have
got that it but I guess in a commercial
I guess her role as like a battered
woman like shame on it and it was an
important issue so I guess maybe that's
why but like there's a difference just
between being really famous and really
influential like like the Rihanna is
[ __ ] influential but there are a lot
of people who are like extreme like
Olivia trade is so influential but she's
not they got famous yet but like she
sells out like if she puts a product I'm
like literally 1 million people will buy
it honestly I think we're really we are
really influential I like to think so I
thought we are like if we say something
I gotta be influential or famous
both no seriously I would definitely
rather be influential business or the
thing both sound good being famous
doesn't guarantee getting money being
influential it guarantees making money
ok so I don't know I think I'd rather be
like rich and like somewhat well-known
then like really well-known with like no
money so everyone knows I have no money
do you know I mean I understand that
this is something I think about a lot ok
let me get into the article there the
two stars who great six we're doing one
more thing I really don't wanna jinx it
like Emily how good of a boy he goes
means you're gonna jinx it and why are
you so surprised he specifically talked
with treats and balls so other
influencers who got the cover treatment
are actress Tiffany Haddish who's
interviewed by Karen Kevin Hart
influential I want to use Groupon pro
tennis player Roger Federer Federer mean
it's not influential Microsoft CEO Satya
Nadella
probably influential yeah and Nitin in
their respective fields and me to
founder Tirana Burke very influential
her tradition each honoree has a few
lines written about them by an equally
famous pier Naomi Watts wrote about best
friend Kidman applauding her saree looks
less than big little higher Theo's water
bottle is it bad is it annoying everyone
okay deal I'm sorry time for a new toy
how is not exciting it's a Christmas
morning toys for the boys go with the
tennis ball
I don't know if he's gonna take the bait
no he totally rejected it's not women he
was dying for the ball before here maybe
a little bit more torn one in the
meantime I'm gonna continue reading this
relatively boring article watching her I
wanted to put my hands through the TV
screen and pluck her from her danger
watts at about Nicole Kidman and big
little eyes that's solely because Nicole
is my friend but because she had laid
herself so courageously bare for the
role that's lesson that it felt real she
could be anyone we know agreed Kerry
Washington penned the feature on
Jennifer Lopez writing that she's to
look up to the star as growing up as a
kid in the Bronx we weren't I know I'm
like just so boring but like just read
me who else was on the West okay yes um
Donald Trump Hugh Jackman gal gadot Hugh
Jackman yes influential as [ __ ] huh gal
gadot is so influential yes I agree he's
amazing Billy Bobby Brown in question
she's like if you don't wear than her
and Jacobs territory's broke up because
he has a girlfriend nudes and as he was
listening like multiple girls for an
idiot but one of the girls recorded the
snapchats that he sent her oh my god
that's vile you know but look that's
what happens in the seventh grade you
know this is very real for a lot of
seventh graders yes oh my goodness
Black Panther director Ryan Coogler
influential Greta Gerwig Roseanne Barr
creditor wake pause Roseanne Barr Jimmy
Kimmel and John Krasinski okay
Jimmy Kimmel I'm so over him he's not
Hardy being very influential about early
Carly do it
if cardi B told me literally to like my
own Tyria and then jump off a bridge
should be like sure just tell me where
do I sign private place Trevor Noah
Kamal Nanjiani of Silicon Valley oh I
watch this as an odd I was oh my god SNL
this week there was one skit that Zach
and I caught that exact in sentiment I'm
gonna be so upset you didn't can I tell
you something though I feel like talking
about SNL skits like ruins them do you
know what I mean okay I'll let you do it
but let's get with a lobster I know I
saw it it's the funniest skit I think
it's about you don't care about us at
all right can I tell you and Ben is a
March so Tom it's about how when you go
to a diner they have so much [ __ ] on the
menu
they weirdly have like lobster for like
no words I know one word is Tessa
okay Davidson like you had a big bags
who goes to the diner he's like I'm
gonna get the lobster they're like wait
what and there's like the prolapsed
airplane by Kenan Thompson of course and
he does it whole like dancing lobsters
so funny wait I'm speaking of SNL
conveyor belt Schumer and Kacey
Musgraves on the 12th of May the dream
team the dream team I'm so [ __ ]
excited I don't know want more excited
for okay that's crazy
by the way I do too because I subscribed
to Kacey Musgraves on Facebook and I got
like an event me too I get it from like
bands in town yeah but I couldn't get it
they're all out know it's like know what
you can't buy ticket says now you have
to be Lorne Michaels which I don't know
someone yeah I think about it just so
rad like do I know them no but like I
might be able to get okay oh that would
be amazing
Megan Marco very influential not gonna
lie Prince Harry obviously Oprah Winfrey
duh and kim jeong-hoon which is like
yeah he's here but Oprah Winfrey said
about I feel pretty no I thought about
it's more than anything she just said
it's like it's the most important movie
of the year like everyone eats it and
then I'm so today I have the night so
much like do you want to talk about it
can I have my headphones wait hold on
hold on I just have one thing and it's
not gonna ruin it no I don't care you
can see my ocean when I saw baby showman
I was so excited for it like I was
waiting months for it that's how I feel
about I feel pretty and when I went in I
had no preconceived notions I made all
my own judgments like even when we talk
about housewives they can tell me about
an episode like then when I watch
episode I think the same thoughts as you
so I'm putting on finesse my cardi B and
Bruno Mars okay you don't want I feel
I'm not even ruining it I'm just giving
you whatever you're so annoying
she really listening okay well what I
was gonna say is that I saw the movie
with Margo who's like a skinny pretty
girl who's like never been fat or like
never had like I know she's never like
doubted herself so like the whole movie
is about like how you really should just
be confident like in yourself no matter
what you look like
what's wrong Theo oh you're choking
you're you're all tangled do better
and like Margolick didn't really like
the movie where it's like I was brought
to tears multiple times and alright I
just feel like and you can't really
appreciate it if you're just like skinny
and pretty do you know what I mean I've
always had someone to talk to about this
but my sister's been so [ __ ] dramatic
that I don't so I will end this segment
like I feel like everyone should see it
it's a really good important movie at
the end singing out that that's what you
do you my baby don't take blame it on
the confidence so I'll blame it on you
Benjamin's shut the [ __ ] down on sight
oh that's right yeah he had Japan and
finesse honestly that's the greatest
idea ever
and Olivia told me to do it because she
saw my desperate Instagram story she was
like she was like you should just put in
headphones and I feel like reinvigorated
- yeah and I feel like weirdly over
adrenaline like I had too much coffee
but that's just the power Bruni Marc
Bruno Mars and cardi B I really love
pruney Mars be straight again so nothing
we have to go to their concert 100% I
went to the Bruno Mars concert and I
know you would take a sensitive topic
cuz you were second I'm supposed to go
with you
I am Draya Bocelli did yeah it was
[ __ ] amazing I know I know I'm gonna
see it or i will literally travel like
if he's playing and like I well like I
will go I want to go to like Atlantic
City or like or in Vegas I'm so damn you
know what the best performance was first
of all he's an amazing performer but the
people he surrounds himself with they're
like just as good the hooligans Willian
and they all do the same dance moves
with saxophones uhm chunky was like so
good I was literally screaming I was I'm
again I'm Jackee I would literally spend
like I would want to sit like front row
because I'm the kind of energy like he
needs feeding back yeah I was in the bed
would spend like thousands of dollars
for those yeah I got freezing after
yesterday's show I went to look up Josh
Groban's tour he's going on tour he's
coming to New York but of course I have
two weddings at night and they wasn't
one November 18th
one in Dallas is the way that I'm gonna
we're gonna be doing in November because
I have a planner but still people don't
another wedding invitations but like two
months before well as people are getting
married in November and they're engaged
yeah
one it was like I found out about one of
them they got engaged like almost a year
ago and then the other one is Cortney
and Josh and that's sabe in Dallas so
then I was looking for other shows that
I could go to and I was like when are
they going to Dallas and it's like two
days before I'm supposed to be in Austin
so I might go see him in Dallas and
tickets are cheaper anyways in case you
are interested but you should definitely
text David Foster okay about it oh for
sure you should text him anyway I know I
should just catch up like how are things
how are things like how's the tour going
yeah has Malaysia he's always a pleasure
because he's I'm really just got talent
yeah how hi baby boys what's our second
story video when you report it today
okay here Kim Kardashian
Yuri launch intimates and shapewear line
Kim kardashian-west this way he'd seen
no time in getting back into the
clothing industry after announcing the
end of - she's already hard at work
under implemented shapewear line I know
and I think it's a missed opportunity
like yes - started as like a fake
intermix and then they never evolved but
now like all of them do merchant
separation it should have been their
official emoji k'kaw Beauty Kylie cuz it
should all be in a sleazy ho a good
American hold it like it's such a missed
opportunity to like translate it into
their merchants like street wear and
although I don't think like they're from
a business perspective like having a
retail store it's just like a losing
battle for them do you know any means
yes but I think it added to their
portfolio sure but they're business
people they don't want to spend money on
things that don't make money like their
businesses are so successful online that
like they don't even need a retail store
did you hear that Kris Jenner made
Tristan Thompson put away ten million
dollars for true because of the cheating
and sign a contract that every time he
gets caught cheating here after he has
to put away another ten million dollars
for her so [ __ ] she's so [ __ ]
that's right I don't think he's that
rich I think has a big contract well you
say get a good
dollar fine and does he have
sponsorships is he like a Nike man
you're like yeah no I don't think so
okay sources close to k'kaw tell TMZ for
the last several months she's been
developing a new brand that will serve
all women world her we're told it's not
just Kim's name that will appear on the
product she's had a hand in just about
every aspect of the Lions foundation
from design to marketing and we'll run
it talked about and how many times have
we heard that I can't enchant yeah but
this is what she should be doing not
copying Kylie no and not being kimochi
like smoking weed is
depends and like shapewear and Yummie
Tummie like this is it this is it that's
what we love him for for her sacred
percent we want to wear her shape I want
her shape I am what I mean I have for
shape this is a big boost nervous I hope
that like I'm just so whoever would not
obviously have this idea and the idea
I'm not here for k'kaw beauty I'm look
not either but like I am because she
sent me the boxes and like I love her so
much I'll support whatever she does I
know but like it doesn't make sense
no just like you don't need to brands no
but like I'm looking famous for so long
and you never made a real beauty line
and then like Kylie and to me like k'kaw
beauty is like a little bit more
costuming and it Kylie cosmetics it's
like what I like would actually use I'm
wearing Kylie today I'm wearing Kylie
every day it's all that I wear every day
I'm what are you wearing I'm Randi Kaye
the new formula I'm wearing passion the
cream lipstick formula and I'm obsessed
with my formula color but you're gonna
get your candy on it really fun no I
don't think it'll be fine
also apparently Tristan makes 16 million
dollars a season right so much is
donated like 70% of yeah the Texas it's
like 9 million yeah
no after taxes it's like zero don't use
lipstick as blush never when you're
desperate looking at the club I'm really
like never that desperate really I'm
always sweating so I guess I haven't
like been it down in the clubs like in a
while and usually when I like get down
like that then I don't really care what
I look like precious beautiful boy she
was such a good boy
um yeah because this next worry is so
boring we need a little extra spice
Rachel Weisz is expecting her first
child with Daniel Craig oh that's nice
she's a nice Jewish girl I saw I mean
yeah Rachel Weisz she's 48 years old no
that's what the page six is saying like
this the thing I'm happy for them but
when I was in college I had to go see a
play that wasn't a musical so I decided
to see the one with Daniel Craig and
Rachel Weisz and like I'll never get
that time or that money back and it
really upsets me so I hate them for now
well she just reminds me of that like
harlot in Definitely Maybe and for that
is good about that move for that reason
I'm out on her look what happened to
chef so cringy somebody oh brother
woman's daughter
yeah and he's were counting to her like
all of his relationships that he's had
and she has to figure out which one is
her mom because she wants to know how he
met her mom
that is like the horrea smoothie ever no
it's at least three girls and they're
all nice actually know what it's like
Mamma Mia Mamma Mia I went to the movies
I saw a sequel yeah my with Cher it's
literally like this and Lily James is
better than that
she was Cinderella and now she's Mamma
Mia young Meryl Streep like it's a shame
like this is what our industry is crying
shame except like dancing queen is an
amazing song no also I was cheated by
you since I don't know when to to do to
do to do the to to so I made up my mind
this must come too and then doo-doo-doo
doo-doo-doo-doo look at me now will I
ever know I don't know how but as
control he's looking so good he's in
love with you like I'll get a liver
monologue a little later on because use
in lieu of talking about Rachel Weisz
and Daniel Craig yeah please talk about
your love for Tina pregnant that's like
biblical but when 98-73 or something
yeah yeah just miracles happen miracles
happen once in a while okay let's take a
minute to talk about the your your
undying love because I'm gonna hit you
with a hard-hitting interview after so
why don't you take a minute to plug your
like no sometimes he misbehaves
sometimes he has accidents were like
when I think of feel like I don't think
of that like to me like him peeing or
whatever like it literally goes right
over my head cuz like I'm so in love
with him and like he totally he changed
all of our lives
how does he change your life
specifically but what do you mean me a
lot more responsible like it's I feel
like I used to go out to literally 6:00
in the morning like on the wheat on the
break of dawn on the Reg but like I
don't really do that anymore trying it
but like three because I like I have
someone to take care of and he has to
pee and like I don't want to like I
don't want it to see me like that you
know what I mean yeah and I just see a
lot better for as well and like it's
really good honestly like like stage in
between like being drunk kid and like
having kids do you know what I mean yeah
so like just like on the surface you
storming responsibility but he's taught
me a lot about like love like I
obviously like love you unconditionally
and like a lot better I actually like
really [ __ ] about feel
unconditionally and like I know this is
gonna sound really bad like since the
day I got him like all I can think about
is like the
he's gonna die and like it makes me
really sad to think about that so sad
but they just got another dog no I know
but like it just really said that like
dogs have to die like faster than human
it's like their whole lives are like big
Chrissy Teigen when her dog died and
that caption she wrote like made me cry
so me and cookie you know what did it
make me cry well when Lisa Vanderpump's
dog died because like she'll have so
many and like you can't have so many
dogs and then like not and then be
surprised but I want to read you Chrissy
Teigen scaption I want her dog died it
was so true and it was so sad ready
Chrissy Teigen I have to scroll down I
know the call from a number that I know
I should have picked it up you know it's
like my couch delivery my couch is
coming today you guys I can't stop
talking about it and I shan't stop
talking about it
ok here I found it ready today our baby
puddy has gone onto the pop heavens John
and I got putty in our first year of
dating when I convinced him have
birthday presents were a real thing just
to be annoying him when she's just
trying to be nice
ten years ago on May 30th they found the
dog that would be there for us through
every up down new house new city new
tour new travel he welcomed new pups and
loved on new babies and new bellies he
was there for everything that's on the
point I want to this is it but the point
he has getting choked this is the tear
jerker it's true what they say we are
their entire lives and it is the
greatest shame that they can't only
bless us with a short amount of time in
ours like it's so sad but someone just
commented something really sweet dogs
have to die before us because they can't
live without us I know but look it just
makes me really sad to think about like
dogs dying well think about all the
happy but the joy and love that he's
brought to your life think about that I
wish we could get a zoom I love it so
much so in his one year on this earth
have you seen like a significant change
in him like how would you say he's
gotten older and why is it he used to
just be like so afraid of everything
like on the street like you literally
couldn't go to the bathroom because like
there was so much sound like it's tough
to be in the city and he came from like
a farm he's a small town farm boy yeah
and now he just like runs the streets
and he like sees big dogs he doesn't
even care like he just owns he's there
his [ __ ] you know ya know he has taken
this city by the bull by the horns he's
taken the city by the horns literally
the best boy he doesn't [ __ ] around
these lights nothing
nothing fazes nothing except the tunnel
faced him a little bit he was a little
nervous in the tunnels right he's just
like look he's so good I think it
seriously like when he dies I'm gonna
kill myself
I'm dead serious Claudia no it's like
I'm what about then what about Steen's
yes what about the toes toasters
honestly if I just if I kill myself with
you know I'm getting suicide it's like
not a joke but like if I had if you have
to replace me here are acceptable
replacement I know sugar okay because
she's great I guess you hadn't given
this much thought no I haven't okay look
it should be on my own so peacefully so
we have six stories today because um
they're all pretty light Michelle
Williams Destiny's Child singer not to
be composed with charity Barnum yeah is
engaged to pastor Chad Johnson not to be
confused with bachelor really the hell
chose us or to say these are terrible I
know that's why there was an alternate
sixth one just because this one really
does stink
I just opened them all excited want to
make a choice that's time because I
figured like all the stories are pretty
thin like we have time I guess it's like
like news happens a lot but because we
go live every day I guess the news
doesn't happen like that much yeah slow
news day is what they call it sleeping
honestly like what's your favorite state
of the year when he's sleeping 11:00
p.m. vo when he's shot say like he's in
the morning she's crazy because he just
slept all day but like towards like 9 10
11 o'clock I'm watching TV before bed
like he gets so tired and he lets you do
whatever you want to him like usually if
I try to make him like sleep on me he'll
like run away but like when he's tired
mmm so delicious
that's so if he when he dies which will
be in 20 years you could get him stuffed
and then he's just like sleeping around
your house and like really I can say
like the impending death like no one
else can so don't ever bring it up again
um sorry I have to hold you accountable
okay death accountability uh someone
said a really sad comment that's also
gonna make you sad what my dog who was
at half Cavalier just passed away last
weekend unexpectedly
cherish her time with him
so no we're gonna get to the house
birthday I mean look at him we're
bumming about birthdays it really puts
things in perspective and it is the
symbol of all of our mortality okay
Reverend I'm inspired by pastor Chad
Johnson Williams congratulations to the
happy couple of pounds daddy showed by
Liam's like needs some positive energies
he got engaged about a month ago she was
on engage like at the Coachella oh yeah
are they gonna perform again together
this weekend meerkat were always been to
eat chickens the same performances yes I
don't know that weird it's like yeah we
all saw it on Instagram you're gonna
pretend again like it's a surprise that
jay-z is there okay next story Kim
Zolciak Biermann is not returning to
real houses in Atlanta
the women refused to shoot with her oh
another one bites best the dust falling
intense drama with NeNe Leakes Kim
Zolciak Peterman will not return to Real
Housewives of Atlanta a source confirms
to Us Weekly Kim and Bravo agreed she
wouldn't come back none of the girls
will film with her they refused the only
one of the cast members who will work
with her is Sheree but it doesn't look
like she's coming back either right
however the news of Zolciak Biermann
leaving doesn't come as much of a
surprise to Andy Cohen the executive
producer reveals an interview on April
13 that he'd be surprised if she
returned she left their reunion really
unhappy I don't think this was a fun
experience for her and so I would be
really surprised if she came back oh
just it's like I hate when the wrong
housewives win do you know what I mean
yeah but you know what justice will be
so she still does have her own show and
I don't yeah that's why she doesn't
she's not fazed by any of this like her
show is lucrative and popular enough
that like she'll be fine and like the
Housewives only work when like all of
the housewives are sort of like on equal
playing field yeah her having our own
Bravo show there's a reason why Bethenny
wasn't a housewife while she was
Bethenny yeah she had to like get a talk
show get humbled and then have to like
come back to housewives because she
didn't have anything else but Kim isn't
in that position she doesn't have to
grovel she doesn't have to make the
women like her and it's just it's not a
fit like if Nene were still on Glee she
wouldn't be on real house they mean II
got so famous she left housewives yeah
new normal she moved to LA like and then
she also had to eat humble pie because
like Ryan Murphy like Sadow's Trump
checks stopped cash in when she would
stop being a housewife it's crazy how
Ryan Murphy
just like plucked her from Atlanta and
was like meet her no Roz Washington her
character ugly is literally the most
iconic epic thing ever I like that was
when she was the best she got a little
too like old lady wise sage vibe and
like it's so condescending yeah
also we only think that like where he
messed up as he should have put her in
screen Queens yeah just as her screen
she might have not been good to work
with
just as her scream queens please she
must have not been pleasant to work with
because like he loves to keep people
around for a long time so Connie Britton
Liam shell Emma Roberts yeah and like
she must have been difficult because
there's no reason that she shouldn't
have been in more projects Marsha
who's Marsha the attorney Sarah Paulson
oh yeah Sarah Bosen Marcia and Clark
really yeah that doesn't feel right that
was I think that was his best work yeah
I think scream Pete's was his best work
it's so underrated and appalling the way
that it wasn't received critically the
way I would have preferred she hears so
much gohmert Glee is obviously his best
record like and he's also nip/tuck
that's crazy
the chuck is the Crazy's also like the
new normal not everyone can be a hit
yeah yeah it was actually a pretty good
show like as far as like those sitcoms
go oh he's dead he's tired
oh he we were sorry mommy boy sorry I
wish we could get like a camera on him
but he's too beautiful
just follow me on snapchat at girls my
job I try Keough problems a pup with no
job at boys no job at Margot's right
I've Olivia shy buddy message isn't
getting my advice an inch
she's really inspiring these days the
attorney leggings that I did not read
the story its day but I'm looking over
your iPad is he kidnapped yeah this is
our sixth story you got a bonus story
that's how bad the stories works
everything to get it we needed to give
one more
Alex Rodriguez's nephew was kidnapped
and held for ransom over a car sale whoa
ABC and Yeti chocolates I was wanted
Norberto susini was reportedly with a
friend who was attempting to sell a
Lamborghini to two men they met up at a
hotel but things took a turn when the
money changed hands a miscommunication
allegedly led the buyers to kidnap the
29 year old holding him in a car against
his will
the men reportedly
ended up walking the minor league
baseball player back to the hotel New
York City Police detectives were waiting
in the lobby and the buyers were
arrested
Seanie was not hurt and the men were set
to appear in court on Thursday I
literally watched an episode of Blue
Bloods like this just last night really
yes someone had the car from the movie
hmm
I want it took him very famous movie
about a car Back to the Future house
it's like this green car Oh cars Oh
Ferris Bueller's Day Off oh no I think
was Herbie fully loaded that would be an
amazing episode of the show that Speed
Racer
lays runner no blaze runner Blade Runner
Blade Runner no that was fast and
furious it was okay I think Blade Runner
2049 it was one word and it was like
racer blaze racer it was like one word
and it was like [ __ ] was it oh you
haven't been watching Riverdale oh my
god I haven't been watching him so oh my
god last episode really maybe we kept
Riverdale and I watched recap Jersey
short because we only like I don't watch
ok Riverdale is back and I'm sick of
these hiatuses like I think they take so
many hiatuses it's not like writer
Ross's fault it's like CW obviously just
doesn't prioritize this show over like I
don't know the State of the Union or
whatever is happening like the Olympics
live Center life sentence which I Love
Lucy hell Joe but I don't want to watch
it man that show bumped dynasty to
Friday night's justice for dynasty
Claudia you have to watch it it's
unbelievable it got picked up for a
season full I just can't no it's like a
one day thing it's literally Gossip Girl
the plot is so good and twisted then
like every time something happens I'm
like how are they gonna get out of this
predicament and then they do and it just
Stevie and they always get out of it no
but like the way that they do it is just
not the way I would have thought even
though I don't understand my Fallon
didn't just marry
Sammy because he needed a green card and
she needed the fake husband so that's
the only part that doesn't make sense to
me give X Riverdale ah back to her oh
but everyone watch trying to see because
like you'll thank me
Riverdale it was the Carrie episode
Margo thought it was weird and I
understood why she did because she did
she's not like a connoisseur of the arts
quite like we are you know it's
difficult when you're you know talking
to someone it was just not the same
intellectual level as you when it comes
to artistry and that's something I
struggle with like pretty much on a
daily basis because there's an artist
myself in multiple fields like you know
kind of
hobnobbing with non-intellectual savages
is it's tough I can imagine that's
probably why you love this show because
here it goes elec xual scholar non-vash
anyways it what the [ __ ] is an
intellectual knowledge non Sam I got I
check it I made up suppose you of course
made about an ounce apologist mind you
asked me also did you see that you're
like has Smosh
what yeah they did the party at
Coachella T were Sahaj you're lying I
swear they called semaj you the a GE
survive cause I made that up they
obviously watch a toast but that's not
surprising because everyone does yeah
everyone but everyone is the same time
it's very strange you know it's like all
the people watch a toast like live in
the ten Baca Sydney of us and then say
happy birthday that's the yellow box on
the street say was like so popular
everyone years old you never look better
you don't look a day over to you know I
would hope you anyways
Riverdale I really enjoyed the carry
musical vibes it was definitely like
weird in they broke out into song at
times when I didn't sing a song was
necessary and like who's singing who's
not does madellaine saying it didn't
sound like her voice and it was just
like kind of weird and they needed
whoever does the lip-syncing syncopation
from Glee because it was just like a
little it wasn't feeling like it was
these people saying I understand but the
episode was really good the 70s dancing
cuz Carrie I guess is a 70s like art she
was like have you ever seen seventh the
Carrie no yes you have because I watched
it growing up and you didn't see it no
oh my god it's so scary looking I don't
watch scary movies
but I like to like the last five minutes
since when is Carrie a musical it's not
okay so they made up these songs maybe
like thanks I'm something interesting
from our new intern Jacob who's starting
next week is that Carrie is like an old
like an 80s movie but they remade it a
few years ago and writer Ross made it
that's why they chose it for the musical
on Riverdale he was like a writer on it
he's just like in the Orion room he's
just like a jack-of-all-trades yeah he's
the Ryan Murphy of Gen Z totally anyway
so I was here for it the ending shook
and it's like almost too graphic
it was insane with the Castle flood
no that's weapons that carry Oh worse
really it was so crazy
I really need to catch up you really
need to catch up and I just I love
Archie and Veronica and I think I'm the
only person but I do too I love like
everything that they're doing together
makes sense to me and I don't know if
I'm supposed to like them or dislike
them but I want them together forever
like I don't want underlying like things
between Archie and Betty like Archie is
for Veronica and Betty's her Jughead and
like that's that also justice for how
like I like it really yeah I don't know
I just feel like he's not that bad of a
guy
and people who ship Alice and FP like
why why though like the woman that
serpent affirmed in that Alice's when
she's with FP is like I prefer her when
she's with her cuz when she says how
she's like making pancakes making mashed
potatoes with like a nice garnish and
just like everyone's always fed like
when she's with FP she's like you know
coming in tonight with her chores she's
coming into like a romper and a demi
lovato so no it's just like that was
weird and like Taylor sailors right
Taylor Swift vibes let me talk you about
Joey short cuz literally nothing
happened and like the episode moves so
slowly and like I'm really just like not
enjoying it
I'm loving while watching these people
back on my TV show TV screens but like I
don't even Margo was here and she is
shipping FP and Alice you know that's
why I said I'm not intellectually not I
not intellect not Sahaj we know a
non-intellectual out yeah and not
intellectual about I can't even recap
what happen on Jersey Shore like Rodney
cheater oh oh my god sorry something did
happen no tell me I don't care this is
an I feel Brittany so they brought home
some girls from the club who like
obviously go to University of Miami
they're like come on me and they were
like really pretty in skinny and like
one of them like Snooki was giving them
so many drinks because she wanted them
to get tired and go to sleep so Ron
wouldn't cheat on his girlfriend with
them and she like made one of them like
so drunk the girl like stumbled out of
the hot tub
she couldn't see straight she couldn't
walk I can't believe they put this on
camera like this girl could be dead for
all we know Snooki like picks her up
sniff he's like a mom now so she's like
taking the girl giving her water
literally Snooki's trying to walk her to
the bathroom the girl falls on the couch
in a bikini she's soaking wet and
literally starts projectile vomiting
everywhere her body is convulsing when
she's throwing up she's like this
and literally like Jackie I can't
believe it this girl must be mortified
like she's just a regular girl like we
know about girls who like went
University of Miami like went to a club
and like tried to get on TV you know
yeah oh my god it was the crate I
couldn't like her body she was in a
bikini so you saw her whole body like
she had throw-up all in his hair makini
yeah she was so skinny
okay she gave me that mortified then
like throw-up non-stop it was so crazy
it was really scary you know when
someone gets like scary drunk but they
caught it on camera it's a help her
weight that gives me a pit also like
that Sookie's fault
no nobody was feeding them dreams just
smokey like felt bad that's why she was
helping her Abra her we don't like give
someone drinks and hope that they get
tired like what was she giving her wine
otherwise no she was getting them vodka
orange juice you don't give that to
someone to get tired and she's probably
the orange juice seems more energy
doesn't yeah it has vitamin C yes
speaking in vitamins I just ordered a do
you seem I've wrote in beauty in the
toast which is our Beauty toasters group
I need to start taking vitamins because
I never have any energy I know that I'm
nutrient deficient and I have something
for you so I put in beauty in the
toasters and I got so many good answers
I've ordered six vitamins but no see
eyes on Instagram and add that I kind of
want to do easy we're gonna put on nurse
Lee like what you want to get out of
vitamins like what you put in your and
then they send you packets everybody
thought I did oh you got a prescribed
where I told them how I called my habit
um should I forget I could check make no
tell me later I will so you tell them
everything about yourself you know your
age where you live what you eat how
often you work out what you're looking
for in vitamin so I said I want more
energy blah blah blah so I'm taking
they're sending me iron which I
definitely need like I'm definitely
ironed you show small and fro and they
say it was steamer to iron and a steamer
vitamin D I believe something like
called Cana which is like for energy
because I just get so me to like
lethargic okay and then one other thing
I forget and they could also get send
you stuff to help with your digestion
I'm pretty like normal so it's good
relax
I'm good on that and then I'm also
getting collagen peptides because my
nails are really thin and they're always
bad but I so I can put that in my coffee
every morning and then Michelle Cheech
me to get electrolyte packets that you
put in your drinks I have so it's like
Pedialyte but like you don't have to
drink a whole Pedialyte and I'm just
feeling so grateful to the toasters for
helping me get my health and check I'm
feeling so grateful to Theo because he's
already been such a good boy
he's obviously too good of a boy because
now we can't bring him back I know
because he's asleep but maybe if it's
begun his behalf because as a mother
Shaunie oh I'll let him speak on my
behalf
okay sure I'll speak as a mother of a
one-year-old how is this year been like
in terms of I guess you already answered
this question is no it's didn't really
challenging actually like in the
beginning I was like damn this sucks now
I know why people are like it's so much
work but like the reward you feel just
by like what he falls asleep in your
arms it's like worth the whole day of
like chasing him around and cleaning up
a [ __ ] you know that's so beautiful and
how do you think that he has changed
since becoming a one-year-old and is he
no longer technically a puppy I think
that difference really come in I don't
know I have to google that I think in
the past 12 hours since turning 12 I
think he's really changed like his
mindset you know yeah he's much more
focused on his future and I just making
a better life for himself yeah and I
feel like he what he puts his mind to
something like there's nothing he can't
accomplish
no I I'd be hard-pressed to find someone
who wouldn't describe Theo as tenacious
tenacious hard worker never never gives
up ever that's like just everything that
you want as humans really learn from
that you know it's Friday we're about to
go into Shabbos we should just reflect
on the type of people were becoming and
maybe we looked at the I was like a
light of our lives to be like hmm maybe
we should be more like him so some
people say that puppies you know have a
lot of energy kind of annoying a lot of
hard work those people would be correct
are you looking forward to him being
less of a puppy are gonna miss these
puppy years let's see this is what said
it's like I can't wait for him to get
old and tired so that he's like a chill
lapdog but then like he's just so much
closer like having his life be over so
you know I'm just grateful for them for
the moment now well we're grateful to
have Theo and he's such an amazing boy
and I feel like that's really a
reflection of his parents I totally
agree and we know what kind of dog mom
you are because you tell us on the show
but it's unfortunate that Slade Smiley
the deadbeat dad is what he has for a
father well that was my next question
how has been handling fatherhood and
what is his relationship because Theo is
a boy no we tend to forget no for sure
but a lot of their son relationship it
was a boy buddy Squad 20 peas when boy
dogs are really supposed to lift their
leg but it's cuz he's surrounded by so
much feminine energy all the time that I
think he's
honey that's what I read online um what
was question so what was a father sent
for son relationship you know how is it
evolved it's definitely evolved because
you've said that Ben didn't want the oh
no and every time Ben like tries to take
that away from me litter I said it last
and I'm like I paid for Theo you don't
even want him like it's so mean but this
is the thing like I am fortunate enough
to work
you know partially from home which is
why I got the dog in the first place
because I feel like people who have like
9 to 6 9 to 5 job who like cam be with
the dog and like they leave him in the
crate all day like that's me and so I
feel like it was a perfect dog owner and
I can't really fault Ben for like having
a real job and like never being able to
hang out with Theo but I do blame him
and I resent it but do you feel that
when Ben does come home at the end of a
long day like he has love for Theo in
his heart he's much loved and he takes a
lot of responsibilities you know of
course I mean there's nothing like a
mother's love we all know that so a lot
of people say they can't put a price on
love yet you're able to purchase a dog
yeah how much would you pay for theum
now having having it on him yes say
someone was gonna take him away unless
you paid how much what suppose my funds
are limited right now so it's not based
on like what I actually have in the bay
it's just more of a mind okay so say
like you have how much percentage of
your total wealth would you give for
Theo like 20% of everything I was is a
50% he's [ __ ] dead that's why he's
such a happy person
middle of the night I literally wake up
and shake him just to make sure he's not
dead because he like doesn't move when
he sleeps he could be dead right now if
you guys have questions for Theo put
them in the chat obviously he's sleeping
but he speaks through his mother's voice
and I just have a couple questions for
Theo
um so he's fortunate enough to have a
few Encinitas and a couple uncle si yeah
how does he feel about his relationship
with his mother how many rank uncles and
aunts you better do me justice okay
number one aunt is I'm sorry Margo she's
at my house all the time taking care of
him whenever I need someone sorry sorry
she's first I'm not saying you have more
more love than her but just in terms of
doing stuff like you can't even pick up
his boot Margret picks up his boot and
you won't put your fingers in his mouth
when you get something is now that's
that's what you're gonna fault me for
this for my own insecurities yes that's
exactly what I'm doing so Margo's
definitely aunt number one and then
uncle number one I would
Douglas was only two uncles his doctor
Pierrot just because zach wine rabbit
and Zack Shapiro loves this is Olivia's
boyfriend he loves Theo and like he said
a big burly man and he loves him yeah so
feel about him sorry Zack is less for
uncle I don't even think he's ever met
the oh I don't even I don't never meant
to be here but definitely like some
animal today
Zach doesn't like him because he sheds
and he's like very annoyed about that
know Zach yeah also I think that there's
some like tension because there's the
two Texas boys in the room and there's a
ha ha totally only remember one of them
that Zach feels like you're giving too
much attention to do and not to your
relationship no not that it's not to my
relationship but he doesn't realize I
could give all my attention to the
relationship but and I still have Theo
attention it's like you could be so full
at dinner and you can t anymore but you
still room for dessert like those
pockets are different even if one is
full or mi here it doesn't affect of
this pocket and I just I wish you
wouldn't know that because I have so
much love for him so yeah and it doesn't
affect my love for the gun for am ii
danceny chest this is the thing it's
like you and Olivia both love Thea and
you love to put them on your snapchat
story like I view it in terms of like
helpfulness and like neither one of you
a relatively help okay but like but
Olivia is truly the worst like she's the
least helpful like I asked her in Diels
entire life one time to help to watch
him and she said no like literally last
week that was the first time ever and I
won't be asking her again so I always
offered my way it sounded like I could
pick up the oh yeah so you definitely be
the Libya but you don't be Margo cuz she
like comes to my house did you pay her
no but I let her like watch TV and order
lunch on my ubereats
must be nice no such thing as a free
lunch um yeah because I have to pay for
it right and because she has watch do
and then my final question for Theo is
he has so many nicknames
um just uh Pawlenty this is a fun game
he's got one put it in our feet one
friends group okay he's like obviously
everyone calls their dog like crazy name
awesome Margo is the number one answer
yes and I'll tell you why because she
captured that video of him watching Law
& Order yeah thank you um John O'Hara
his nicknames oh so someone put in our
feel and friends like dog toaster group
like what is the evolution of your dog's
name because obviously they have a born
name but then like you call
nicknames and you get to where you
getting this girl's dog's name it's like
Abigail and she gots like Lord Abington
so let's start with you Mufi to the dark
days Theo to tayo tayo to TTA to Tigs
know anytime you get from tayo to
tickety it's tayo to Tigs no that's not
right it's tayo and then be like man yo
me satay and then we were like tickety
Tay then we just cut it out Tigs
then T there takes the boy senior teams
so we kind of evolved from there and
then he's also the pretty boys the boys
with the toys he's a toy Beastie Boys
the Backstreet Boys the feast II boy ya
lose everything the Hardy Boys oh I
don't we also didn't even go down like
the loophole of like precious boy
nutrition sports superstitious for
precious nutritious boy so it's just
still is just precious superstitious
nutritious boy so yeah baby boys mm-hmm
he's of the full bad boy he's one year
the baddest I'm so excited to see where
we are near from now see like what we're
gonna trim again and all the nicknames
we'll have for him then I wish we sort
of had this like for all of like the
speech s and the scenes like I was where
it came from
all really stems from Margo's vision
yeah until I lived only we can make like
that one if only like David Foster wrote
that song then the world would really
work for me breath I feel like I'll wake
him up now and let him and let him know
no let him he's not really dead we need
to do a toast okay
obviously the Theo you've been in light
of my life I literally would die without
you I love you more than anything in the
world thank you for teaching me so much
about like love and respect and thank
you for always being why you love Hannah
toes because this person John O'Hara
like really watches every episode
intently because he used kids said a
nickname that I forgot about what Marin
Thea's name was dandy because dandy
Hanson I remember but where do we come
up with that oh my god John O'Hara I'm
crying you Jenner hair for interrupting
my speech I will start again
as a movie a toast a toast to Theo the
boy who taught us all about love and
respect and just what it means to be a
truly precious boy and what it means to
be a good man in this world and that
some justice we need to serve today
justice you know what for all the dogs
but mostly the Cavaliers who aren't as
lucky as Theo who are being abused I
follow these crazy [ __ ] accounts
about like the Cavalier rescue of
Alabama and they do such good work but
like it's [ __ ] [ __ ] and if you've
ever abuse an animal like that Instagram
model in the elevator did you see that
video hmm I hope she dies like okay
sorry that's me to say but like she's an
animal she well that's an insult to
animals yeah she's a [ __ ] beast and
she deserves you had that thing anywhere
that people could go to see yes I follow
the Cavalier lines I'm just obsessed
with Cavaliers but like you should save
all dogs but the cavalier Cavaliers have
like a heart problems and like
congenital heart failure so they require
a lot of extra love and they also have
shorter lifespans sorry so the Cavalier
alliance and I follow a Facebook group
called tube the Cavaliers about that my
something like that I'll share it all on
it on our page but I had Alabama
cavalier that's what Theo needs no it's
just another together in Cavalier rescue
organization is based in Alabama cuz
they do a lot of like puppy mill
auctions and down in the South literally
my friend Amanda who also has a cavalier
whose birthdays for 21 we're going to
his party on Sunday she sends me the
saddest stuff like literally this girl
who works at a Cavalier line it's like
was riding in her hometown and saw a
pickup truck with like Cavaliers in the
back like bound together in like a cage
I'm like she's like literally followed
it and rescued the dogs thank you guys
so much for tuning in happy birthday to
Theo please go to his Facebook I mean
his engage pup with Nigel leave him some
birthday love he really what he breeds
it I read them all to him every night
that's our show happy amazing weekend we
have a nice for 22 I celebrate safely we
are not in the studio next week so
starting on okay Monday through Friday
and then we'll be back on Tuesday we're
traveling back on Monday so Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday we are
releasing podcast episodes only so make
sure you're subscribed to the morning to
podcast app they're gonna be good
morning toast and subscribe because that
is where our show will be next week
there will be no video we're gonna
obviously to Fast Five it'll be juicy
celeb gossip but then we're gonna have
on some of your favorite guest some of
your favorite and some of your favorite
uncle's just kind of talking about
their lives what it's like to be a part
of our family who their least favorite
sister is things like that it's gonna be
really juicy so make sure you subscribe
to the podcast app in the I mean make
sure to subscribe to the morning toast
in the podcast app that is what we have
for you have an amazing game Tree on
will be starting on the 1st of May so
definitely go sign up because you don't
want to miss it
see ya but Welcome feel hi boys